No
world of acquiring work for an auction
catalog is,
it's quite hilarious because it's,
it's definitely this insane high,
low aspect to everything that we do
because on one hand there is very much
that kind of populist,
I'm making somebody rich overnight
appeal to putting together an auction,
which is very addictive.
Um,
there's nothing greater than,
you know,
when the proverbial elderly lady in Rock
Chester writes you and says,
you know,
I saw you on some,
Internet site.
It sounds like you're,
I have this piece of furniture.
Is this by,
you know,
Carla Molino,
my,
my parents acquired it at a department
store and 1938 in New York.
And it is,
and it's,
so there's that aspect.
We have a one off relationship with the,
with the,
the client that pulls the declaration of
independence out of their basement.
At the other time you have longterm
relationships with pickers.
The guys in vans who'd go out there and
find the stuff that people are not savvy
enough to call us about the stuff that
goes through a state sales,
the stuff that ends up in foreclosure
auctions.
The things that get put left out by the
side of the road.
If you don't have a good network of,
of,
of dudes and vans in the postwar design
business,
you're finished.
And you've got to maintain excellent
relationships with them so that they
bring the peace to you and not to your
competitors.
But on the other side,
the high side of the coin,
um,
there's nothing more exciting than
meeting with curators in a museum who've
decided to deaccession apiece,
who've decided that,
um,
you know,
this piece isn't right for their
collection and they would like to sell
that piece to bring more money into
create,
get more pieces.
Um,
in December we sold a grand piano by
Gilbert Rhodey from the Museum of Modern
Art's collection.
And the piano had been in their
auditorium and was being used by the
Department of film to accompany silent
movies.
But as a piece,
it's a piano.
And even though this was an extremely
rare piece by a very unsung 1930s
American industrial designer,
it's a piano and piano is very,
very hard thing for a museum to display.
So they sold it with us.
And you know,
nothing more exciting than,
you know,
having that kind of provenance.
You know,
when,
when putting together a catalog and,
and finally we were working with,
you know,
I continue to work with some of the
great collectors out there and with
them,
well,
they already know much more than I do in
many of these areas.
It's more a question of meeting with
them and going,
well,
you know,
what do you want to do now?
What you know,
you want to sell right?